Amazon has yet another massive hit on its
hands in the form of "Reacher."
The series has given audiences a towering
new action hero to look up to.
The 1st season of "Reacher" proved an immediate
success for the streaming service, following
the former soldier as a drifter who finds
himself embroiled in a criminal conspiracy
in a small Georgia town.
The show has proven so successful, in fact,
that it's already been greenlit for a 2nd
season.
"Trouble just kinda seems to find me."
The soldier-turned-detective at the heart
of "Reacher" might look familiar to fans of
the series.
That's because the action hero is portrayed
by Alan Ritchson, an actor with a career full
of great performances in the world of action
and comedy.
With "Reacher" becoming the monumental hit
that it is, and with more action on the way,
now is the time to dive in and take a look
at some of the most notable roles and performances
that fans may know Alan Ritchson from over
the years.
One of the first major on-screen roles that
many audience members may recognize Alan Ritchson
from is his role as Arthur "AC" Curry in "Smallville."
Introduced to the show during Season 5 in
2005, Ritchson would go on to appear on The
WB's Superman prequel series four times until
2010.
"You're not going anywhere."
The popularity of the Aquaman character on
"Smallville" eventually led to a planned spinoff
for the character.
However, when the "Aquaman" series went to
pilot, Ritchson was ultimately recast.
Despite not playing Aquaman in live-action
outside of his tenure on "Smallville," Ritchson
would eventually go on to reprise his Aquaman
role in voiceover for the animated film, "Justice
League: The New Frontier," in 2008.
Alan Ritchson has played several athletes
over the course of his career, but perhaps
his most well-known athlete performance is
his role as Thad Castle in the Spike TV comedy
series "Blue Mountain State."
Though initially pitched as a soft antagonist
who bullied and hazed his teammates, Thad
eventually became the co-lead of the series
in the show's 2nd and 3rd seasons.
Outside of his work in the DC and "Reacher"
universes, Thad Castle may arguably be one
of Ritchson's defining performances as an
actor.
"Cocaine.
Yeah baby."
In 2016, Ritchson reprised the role of Thad
in earnest for the "Blue Mountain State" spinoff
movie: "Blue Mountain State: The Rise of Thadland."
Another high-profile film series where you
might have caught Ritchson was "The Hunger
Games."
He portrayed Gloss, one of the most gifted
and talented tributes in the games.
A career combatant from District 1 who specialized
in throwing knives, Gloss battled Katniss
and the other returning winners in "The Hunger
Games: Catching Fire," alongside his sister
Cashmere.
Ritchson's tenure in "The Hunger Games" franchise
was ultimately short-lived.
If "Blue Mountain State" proved he could catch
a football, "The Hunger Games" showed he was
just as good at doing it with arrows.
But even though Gloss went down, Ritchson
was going nowhere but up in Hollywood.
After putting in a few cameos in popular shows
like "New Girl," Ritchson landed one of the
leads in a very different type of comic adaptation:
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Although you couldn't see his face, he provided
the voice and motion capture for Raphael.
"Actually I'm in charge on this one."
In 2018, Alan Ritchson found himself back
in the DC universe in the role of Hank Hall,
a.k.a Hawk, in "Titans."
A former football player who eventually became
a vigilante, Hank was a brutal fighter who
patrolled the streets in a Hawk-themed outfit.
He was one half of the "Hawk and Dove" crime-fighting
duo, balancing out the more nuanced and finesse-oriented
fighting style of Dove with a brute force
approach.
As Hawk, Ritchson would make several appearances
across various DC properties.
In addition to his primary role on "Titans,"
he also briefly appeared on "Supergirl" during
the "Crisis on Infinite Earths" crossover
event.
Unfortunately for Hawk, the character ultimately
met his demise during "Titans" Season 3.
Ritchson has continued to appear on "Titans"
in sequences following Hank into the afterlife,
but at this time, the character remains canonically
dead.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.